هل هذا في حسابات الولايات المتحده الا تض
دول المنطقه في حربها مع الحوثيين او مع
ما يسمى ب وكلاء ايران في
المنطقه لدينا البحرين التي انضمت الينا
في قوه مهام في مواجهه الحوثيين لكن دول
اخرى كندا وهولندا
كدول تعتمد ايضا على التجاره
ال العالميه وايضا القوه المهام التي قمنا
بانشائها مع 30 دوله اخرى اعتقدوا ان هذه
هذه القوه فيها الكثير من الدول لان
الكثير من التجاره العالميه تمر عبر قناه
السويس والى البحر الاحمر بالتالي نحن
نشرك هم بشكل اساسي لم نريد ان نشرك دول
اخرى بنسبه لرد على الهجمات التي استهدفت
الامريكيين
لان انه في حقيقه الامر كان كانت قواتنا
موجوده في العراق بسبب طلب الحكومه هناك
وكانت ايضا ايضا
كانت قواتنا نشرت هناك بسسبب وجود القاعده
وتنظيم الدوله بعد ذلك وكان مساله وجودنا
هناك الامر لا يتعلق باسرائيل او غزه لكن
كان وجودنا في العراق كان بسبب طلب
الحكومه التي ارادت وجدنا من اجل حمايتها
من تنظيم الدوله وكانت قواتنا ايضا موجوده
في الشمال بسبب وجود الكثير من عناصر
تنظيم الدوله هناك ننوه ايضا الى مجموعه
من الاخبار العجله ابقى معنا سيد لاري
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه تقول ان
الاهداف شملت القياده والسيطره وانظمه
صواريخ وعمليات المسيرات
ورادارات ومروح
قالت ايضا ان الضربات ركزت على اهداف في
اليمن تستخدم من قبل الحوثين لمهاجمه
السفن وايضا هنالك حديث
عن ضرب
مخازن السلاح والذخيره تحت الارض ولذلك
استخدمت قنابل زنه 2000 رطل يعني حوالي
1000 كيلو جرام لاستهداف هذه المخازن تحت
الارض وبالتالي نحن نتحد السيد لاري كرب
عن ضربه مختلفه عن الضربات السابقه هذه
الضربه ضربه
مركزه يعني
اهدافها اكثر اكثر اتساعا وايضا الذخيره
والقنابل التي استخدمت اكثر من ذي قبل
ا وبالتالي ربما يعني ما النتائج المرجوه
منها في هذه الحاله هل بالفعل يمكن ان
توفر امنا اكثر
في الممرات المائيه لسيما و ان كثير من
السفن الان حولت مسارها الى راس الرجاء
الصالح اعتقد ان ما قامت به هذه الهجمات
هي دمرت المعدات التي يستخدمها الحوثيون
من اجل استهداف السفن والسؤال الحقيقي هو
هل ستستمر ايران بتجهيز الحوثيين بهذه
المعدات التي استخدموها على الرغم من انهم
يعرفوا ان انهم لا يريدوا حربا اوسعه
وبشكل مباشر مع الولايات المتحده مره اخرى
عندما تعامل مع الحوثين كنا نتسم بالحذر
نحن نحاول ان لا نستهدف الناس فقط المنشات
والمعدات التي يستخدمونها لكن حقيقه انه
زادت كثافه هذه الهجمات هذا مؤشر على اننا
س نعمل بجهد من اجل منع الحوثيين من اجل
ان ان يقوم نوقفهم عن تعطيل الملاح العالم